نحاول أن نلتقط
جانبًا أو اثنين من الجوانب الأساسية لدولة قطر
التي تجعل
شخصيتها إلى حد كبير أحدهما هو
القرب من البحر ،
لذا فإن فكرة القوارب
وفكرة النخيل كانت بالنسبة
لنا أساسية
لتقديم نوع من
الشرارة.
أعتقد أن الجزء الأكثر صلة بالموضوع
هو حقيقة أن الجناح
حديث
هو شلل الأطفال المعاصر
[موسيقى]
ويعرض نفسه إلى المستقبل مهما كان ذلك
قائمًا على
تقاليده ويستند أيضًا إلى
الجذور العميقة لطبيعته الجغرافية.
والتاريخ
وتوليف ذلك هو
الجناح نفسه الذي تراه يوجد شوفان
أو يمكن للناس رؤية كلاهما حتى يمكنهم رؤية
القليل من الماء على كلا الجانبين.
فوق سطح الجناح بالقدر
المسموح به من
أجل إعطاء فكرة
التخصص وأيضًا لتكون قادرًا على عرض
العناصر المتعلقة بتاريخ قطر بطريقة دقيقة
للغاية ، ثم هناك غرفة أخرى في
يمكنك رؤية جوانب الوجوه الحية
للأشخاص ، فهناك جزء منفصل
أكثر في الفريق
نسميه الشخص الذي لا مثيل له
والذي يحمل التقاليد العربية
المتمثلة في وجود غرفة خاصة جدًا
حيث تستضيف أصدقاءك المقربين جدًا ،
إنها طريقة رائعة لذلك  الحفاظ على
كرم الضيافة
كمهندس معماري مع
مئات الأشخاص ، ما تفعله هو
قيامك بإنشاء قطعة معمارية
ولكن قطعة العمارة
مستقلة بذاتها ، فهي تعيش في حد
ذاتها الواجهة بين
الهندسة المعمارية
وواقع كونك
مبنى في ردود
أفعال  الأشخاص خاصة أولئك الذين يتعين
عليهم إلقاء نظرة على الجناح في النشاط اليومي
وكيف يتقبلونه
كيف يعتبرونه جناحًا خاصًا
بهم وهكذا وأعتقد أن هذا
دائمًا جزء مؤثر للغاية
[الموسيقى]
أنت